This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. My SUV is worth more than ever. Time to upgrade? There's never been a better time. At Plaza Auto Group locations get top value for your trade and shop hundreds of new and pre-owned vehicles across 11 locations. And if you can't come to us, we'll come to you.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。保证是真人。我的 SUV 比以往任何时候都更有价值。是时候升级了吗？现在正是最佳时机。在 Plaza Auto Group 的门店，您的旧车置换可享受最高估值，并在 11 家门店选购数百辆全新和二手车。如果您不能来找我们，我们会去找您。
With best in class pricing, unbeatable trade values, and 70 years of trust. It's easy to see why families choose the Plaza Auto Group. Plaza Auto Group, Celebrating 7,000. 70 years, family owned and operated. Visit Plaza Autogroup.com. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The Dream of the 90s is alive in podcast form.
拥有同级最佳的定价、无与伦比的置换价值以及长达 70 年的信赖。不难看出为什么家庭会选择 Plaza Auto Group。Plaza Auto Group，庆祝 7000。70 年来，家族拥有并经营。访问 Plaza Autogroup.com。嘿，波特兰迷们。Carrie Brownstein 和 Fred Armisen 在这里。“90 年代的梦想”以播客的形式重现。
We're launching Podlandia, A.O. Rewatch, our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysler, the mayor, himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song about it.
我们正在推出 Podlandia, A.O. Rewatch，这是我们的全新播客，我们将一起重温《波特兰迪亚》的每一集，剖析小品，深入探讨我们标志性的角色，并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后花絮。我们还将邀请那些帮助将其变为现实的人。客串明星、合作者和朋友，包括导演 Jonathan Chrysler、市长本人 Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐家 Amy Mann 等等。Kyle 在这里全力以赴。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首关于它的歌。
Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam, it's sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the hosts of everyone watches women's sports. a new podcast from Together.
嗯，我以为你们都要写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听 Podlandia. A.O. Rewatch，可在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听。大家好，我是体育记者 Ari Chambers。嘿，你们好吗？我是你们的女孩 Sam J。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》的主持人，这是 Together 的全新播客。
We're breaking down the biggest headlines, the viral moments, and the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. From game-changing performances to culture shifting conversations we'll give you our takes, our debates, and a few laughs along the way.
我们将剖析各大头条新闻、病毒式传播的时刻，以及每个人在女子体育界都在谈论的故事。从改变比赛的表达到改变文化的对话，我们将为您提供我们的看法、辩论，并在这一过程中带来一些欢笑。
Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Jake Brennan, and on the Disgraced Land podcast, I explore the wild lives of rock stars, an unbelievable
因为每个人都在看女子体育。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcast 或您获取播客的任何地方收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。我是 Jake Brennan，在《Disgraced Land》播客中，我探索了摇滚明星的狂野生活，以及音乐史上难以置信的真实犯罪故事。
true crime stories from music history. These are the stories you haven't heard, the kind you'll end up telling someone else. Like the time Paul McCartney spent in a notorious prison or the bizarre crime Lady Gaga is accused of or that time Blondie's Debbie Harry escaped Ted Bunny. Listen to Disgraceland on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
这些都是你没听过的事实，会让你忍不住讲给别人听的故事。比如 Paul McCartney 在臭名昭著的监狱里度过的时光，或者 Lady Gaga 被指控的离奇犯罪，或者 Blondie 的 Debbie Harry 逃脱 Ted Bundy 追捕的那次经历。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Disgraceland。
This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. the world gets crazier, and Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men. Do better or do less, so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika, and I'm out.
我是来自《Dear Chelsea》的 Chelsea Handler。每周，新闻都在变得更糟，世界变得更加疯狂，而 Yamanika 来这里是为了告诉任何负有责任的人，你才是问题所在。你知道我刚刚发现 Sidney Sweeney 是谁吗？如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。要么做得更好，要么做得少一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。我是 Yamanika，我先走了。
Listen to You're the Problem with Yamanika on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. Hello, everybody. I'm Jemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s. podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. If you're watching on Netflix, I promise you I'm not wearing my pajamas. I just need
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcast 或您获取播客的任何地方收听 Yamanika 的《You're the Problem》。大家好。我是 Gemma Spike，欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》。这是一个播客，我们在其中讨论 20 岁时的重大变化、时刻和过渡，以及它们对我们心理学的意义。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。很高兴你能来到这里，回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们将在节目中剖析我们 20 岁时的心理学。如果你在 Netflix 上观看，我向你保证我没有穿睡衣。我只是需要
to say that I've just looked at my outfit and realized that it looks very pajama-like, but it's not and considering we're talking about productivity today, it's kind of ironic. But yes, that's what we're talking about. We're talking about productivity. Specifically, I wanted to share seven of the best, most underrated least spoken about tips to just get more stuff done by doing less. I love these episodes. I love doing them sometimes.
说一下，我刚刚看了看我的 outfit，发现它看起来非常像睡衣，但其实不是，考虑到我们今天谈论的是生产力，这有点讽刺。但是的，这就是我们今天要谈论的。我们讨论的是生产力。具体来说，我想分享七个最好、最被低估、最少被提及的技巧，只需做更少的事就能完成更多的工作。我喜欢这些节目。有时我真的很喜欢做这些节目。
And I feel like so many of us in our 20s, we have these huge ambitions and these projects and these tasks that we want to undertake. And we also feel like we don't have any time when we're working really hard. and like anything that can help us a little bit, anything that can like psychologically nudge us in the right direction, especially when those tips are back by science, are great. And I thought, you know what, let's do an easy episode today. One that's just, let's just do a little list episode. Let's just go through the science, find what works best.
我觉得我们二十多岁的人当中，有很多人都有着宏大的抱负、项目以及我们想要承担的任务。而且我们也觉得自己没有时间，因为我们工作真的很努力。任何能给我们一点帮助的东西，任何能在心理上将我们推向正确方向的东西，尤其是当这些技巧有科学依据时，都是极好的。我想，你知道吗，今天我们做一个轻松的节目。一个只需做个小型清单的节目。让我们来看看科学，找出最有效的方法。
I'm going to deliver it to you guys in a simple package form. And I just sincerely hope it helps you be more productive, be more efficient, but also enjoy your life. as well. Let's get into it. So I think one of the biggest lies about productivity that we've been sold is that discipline is like the singular most important ingredient or factor that is driving productivity. The people who you admire, who get stuff done, they just have this inherent trait that you don't. And although they may have it inherently, although they didn't really have to do anything to get it, your inability to access it yourself, that though is a personal character floor or a fault. And until you can unlock or access your discipline, it's not happening for you.
我将以一个简单的打包形式交付给你们。我真诚地希望这能帮助你们提高生产力，提高效率，同时也享受你们的生活。废话不多说，我们切入正题。所以我想关于生产力，我们被灌输的最大谎言之一是，自律是推动生产力最重要、唯一的要素或因素。那些你钦佩的、能把事情做好的人，他们只是拥有你所没有的这种内在特质。虽然他们可能天生就具备这种特质，虽然他们不需要做什么就能得到它，但你无法自己获取它，这却是一个个人的性格缺陷或缺点。在你能解锁或获取你的自律之前，这一切都不会发生在你身上。
Good luck. Like, it's just not happening. You need to be disciplined or nothing else. I think this is a rather kind of narrow, unfair, like psychologically inaccurate way to think about productivity that really just tries to shame us for what we haven't been able to do without thinking about why we haven't been able to do it. Here is the thing. Our productivity is not to reliant on discipline alone. In fact, discipline is only about 25 to 30 percent of the equation and it's actually what we would call a spark. It is a cognitive spark, not a cognitive fuel source. Discipline is incredibly finite. It's incredibly influenced by so many other factors we often ignore like our sleep, our hormones, our stress, the difficulty of the task, the environment you're in, you're established,
祝你好运。就像，这根本不会发生。你需要自律，否则什么也做不成。我认为这是一种相当片面、不公平、从心理学角度来看并不准确的生产力思考方式，它试图为我们未能做到的事情而羞辱我们，却根本不考虑我们为什么没能做到这一点。事实是这样的。我们的生产力并不完全依赖于自律。事实上，自律只占方程式的 25% 到 30% 左右，它实际上是我们所说的火花。它是一个认知火花，而不是认知的燃料来源。自律是极其有限的。它极大地受到我们经常忽视的许多其他因素的影响，比如我们的睡眠、荷尔蒙、压力、任务的难度、你身处的环境、你建立的、
habits, your past experiences, your confidence in yourself that this is stuff that we don't always seem to like consciously think of as a factor. It's so easy for us to like put it all down to this one thing alone, this neat discipline explanation and just kind of ignore the rest. And it's, you can't ignore the rest. That is an equal part. In fact, there's a really notable meta-analysis that was conducted by the psychologist Pierce Steele, in which he describes procrastination, not as a discipline problem, but a form of self-regulatory failure.
习惯、你的过去经历、你对自己的信心，这些似乎都不是我们总是有意识地认为是因素的东西。我们太容易把它全部归咎于这一件事，这种整洁的自律解释，然后某种程度上忽视其余的。而且，你不能忽视其余部分。那是一个同等重要的部分。事实上，有一项由心理学家 Pierce Steele 进行的非常著名的元分析，他在其中将拖延症描述为一个自我调节失败的形式，而不是一个自律问题。
Importantly, what the paper does not say is that procrastination is about laziness. He actually found that procrastination was primarily shaped by emotional regulation and how unpleasant the task was, that a mental state that you were in, how impulsive you were, whether we believe we could do it, how capable we were feeling, our mental health, like our inability to do certain things is not about mental fortitude.
重要的是，这篇论文并没有说拖延症是关于懒惰的。他实际上发现拖延症主要是由情绪调节和任务有多令人不愉快所决定的，也就是你当时的精神状态、你的冲动程度、我们是否相信我们能做到、我们感觉自己有多大能力、我们的心理健康，比如我们无法做某些事情并不是因为心理坚韧度。
It's about, yeah, your emotional state and your emotional gooniness and how you're feeling. We also know that willpower and discipline are, firstly, don't always factor in those things. they're also mentally very exhausting, and that actually lessens our performance on other tasks afterwards. There is this finding that came from a 1988 study by Beaumister and colleagues where they put people in a room, they put them in front of a plate of cookies and a bowl of radishes, both on the table, and they asked half the participants to not have a cookie. You can have a radish, you can't have a cookie. And they told the other half, you can have one cookie, you can have a cookie. and then they left the room and they just kind of were like, just don't do it.
而是关于，是的，你的情绪状态和你的情绪状态，以及你的感觉。我们也知道，意志力和自律首先并不总是考虑到这些事情。它们在精神上也极其消耗精力，而这实际上会降低我们随后对其他任务的表现。有一个发现来自 Baumeister 及其同事在 1988 年进行的一项研究，他们把人们带到一个房间里，让他们坐在桌前，桌上放着一盘曲奇和一碗萝卜，他们要求一半的参与者不要吃曲奇。你可以吃萝卜，但不能吃曲奇。他们告诉另一半人，你可以吃一块曲奇，你可以吃曲奇。然后他们离开房间，只是类似地，只是不要吃。
You guys be in charge of correcting or following through this action. They then made people do a geometric puzzle. People who had the cookie, they did the puzzle for 19 minutes. Those who had the radish, eight minutes. And it wasn't just the sugar rush. It was the fact that they had to draw on all this willpower to resist the cookie. And it's assumed that that kind of drained their self-control for all subsequent situations. So when you are constantly only relying on willpower and discipline to get stuff done,
你们负责纠正或贯彻这个行动。然后他们让人们做一个几何拼图。吃了曲奇的人，他们做拼图做了 19 分钟。吃萝卜的人做了 8 分钟。这不仅仅是因为糖分的刺激。而是因为他们必须调动所有的意志力来抵御曲奇。人们推测，那种做法消耗了他们对之后所有情况的自我控制能力。所以，当你总是只依靠意志力和自律来把事情做完时，
you know, to help you study harder, to help you avoid temptation, to help you, I don't know, lose weight, the effort that you have for other areas of your life and the discipline or the motivation you have for other things declines. This is why relying on discipline is an incomplete way to look at our productivity. What we actually need to be addressing is that emotional thing, that we're reducing the emotional resistance of the task or the goal in question and also setting up our structures and our behaviors and our surroundings so that the easier thing is the easier thing. Like the thing we want to do has the least resistance. So that really informs, I think it's important to say this because this informs what we're going to talk about next,
你知道，为了帮你更努力地学习，帮你避开诱惑，帮你，我不知道，减肥，你留给生活其他领域的精力和你对其他事情的自律或动力就会下降。这就是为什么依赖自律是看待我们生产力的一个不完整的方式。我们真正需要解决的是那种情绪上的东西，即我们在减少相关任务或目标的情绪阻力，同时也在建立我们的结构、行为和周围环境，以便让更简单的事情真正变得简单。就像我们想做的事情具有最小的阻力。所以这真的为我们接下来要讨论的内容奠定了基础，我认为说这一点很重要，
which is the seven best things that you can do based on that knowledge of discipline. And now, of course, this isn't going to turn you into like a 12 hour a day working machine. To be honest, I don't think you guys know me by now. I really don't care about that. Like I really think that hustle culture and like the girl boss 5,000 work all day, sleep on your dead archetype is dead and should be left there. But I also believe in in devotion and being able to prove to yourself what you're capable of. And I think this stuff takes us to that space and gets us into that mindset in a much more healthy and sustainable way, rather than this like alternative that seems to be the only alternative, which is if you are not actively suffering for what you want, and if you are not actively in a
也就是基于对自律的这种认知，你可以做的七件最好的事情。现在，当然，这不会把你变成一个每天工作 12 小时的机器。说实话，我不认为你们现在还不了解我。我真的不在乎那个。我真的认为内卷文化和那种“打工狂魔，全天候工作，在死去的原型上睡觉”的时代已经死了，应该被留在那里。但我也相信奉献精神，以及能够向自己证明自己的能力。我认为这些东西以一种更健康、更可持续的方式将我们带入那个空间，让我们进入那种心态，而不是像另一种似乎是唯一的替代方案那样——如果你没有为你想要的东西积极受苦，如果你没有积极处于
constant state of exhaustion, you must not want it that much. This is the middle ground. This is the middle ground where you get stuff done, but you also can enjoy your life. So productivity hack number one is the three to one equation. This is a method of structuring your to-do list so that your day is both focused and varied and therefore productive. Every day, if you want to feel accomplished, your to-do list should contain three chores, two small tasks, and one big task. That might look like your three chores are wash your bedding, like vacuum your room, take the bins out, pay your parking fine, like those kind of things. Things that are like admini, they're a little bit annoying, but like you know you need to get done. The two smaller
持续的筋疲力尽状态，你一定不是那么想要它。这是中间地带。这是一个中间地带，在这里你既能完成工作，也能享受生活。所以生产力秘诀一：三二一公式。这是一种构建待产清单的方法，让你的每一天既专注又丰富多彩，从而提高效率。每天，如果你想获得成就感，你的待产清单应该包含三项杂务、两项小任务和一项大任务。这可能看起来像是你的三项杂务是洗床单、吸尘房间、倒垃圾、支付停车罚单之类的事情。那些带有行政性质、有点烦人，但你知道必须完成的事情。两项较小的
tasks are things like, okay, clear out my email inbox from like the night, from the day before. Every little email that I've been avoiding, I'm going to get that done today. I'm going to write my project update. I'm going to send out that important document. There's a meeting I've been putting up. I'm going to do that important meeting. I'm going to do the first two hours of planning for that trip, that event, that important work thing.
任务是诸如：好吧，清理前一天晚上的电子邮件收件箱。每一封我一直在逃避的小邮件，我主要在今天搞定它。我要写我的项目更新。我要发出那份重要的文件。有一个我一直搁置的会议。我要开那个重要的会议。我要为那次旅行、那个活动、那个重要的工作事情做前两个小时的规划。
And then you have the one big task. This is like the meat of the sandwich. So this is the thing that you can expect to spend three to four hours. on or longer. Mine is always the same writing scripts, but for you, it may be writing large sections of a report or an essay, a concentrated study for an exam, doing complex equations, making a major headway on a project. Again, it is the meat in the sandwich, or if you're a vegetarian, it's, I don't know, the tofu in a sandwich. The reason this works is that it gives your brain a balanced sense of progress. Notice how the big task is still really sizable,
然后你有一项大任务。这就像三明治里的肉。所以这是你可以预计花三到四个小时或更长时间去做的事情。我的一直都是写剧本，但对你来说，它可能是写报告或论文的大部分内容，为考试进行集中学习，做复杂的方程式，在项目上取得重大进展。同样，它是三明治里的肉，或者如果你是素食主义者，它是，我不知道，三明治里的豆腐。之所以行之有效，是因为它给你的大脑一种平衡的进展感。请注意大任务仍然相当可观，
but it doesn't take over your entire day. A lot of us either overload our day with a lot of those tiny tasks that make us feel busy but not meaningfully fulfilled. All what we do is we do is we put one absolutely huge intimidating task on the list and then we feel like a failure if we don't complete the entire thing. Again, we are looking for balance. The 3-2-1 method gives you both momentum and cognitive diversity. And that cognitive diversity is so important for your brain so that it can be challenged by different things
但它并没有占据你的整整一天。我们中的很多人要么用大量那些让我们觉得忙碌但没有真正获得满足感的小任务来超载自己。或者我们做的是，我们在清单上放了一个绝对巨大、令人生畏的任务，如果我们没有完成整个任务，我们就会觉得自己是个失败者。同样，我们追求的是平衡。三二一方法为你同时带来动力和认知多样性。而这种认知多样性对你的大脑非常重要，这样它就能接受不同事物的挑战，
so that it experiences the refreshing and the important power of novelty. You know, the three chores, the two small tasks, visible progress. but they also, and you know, they reduce like a lot of the menial stuff as well, they give you progress. They also clear out the clutter of maybe things that you've been putting off. And then the one big task sits in the middle. And it means that you actually feel a meaningful sense of accomplishment at the day, at the end of the day, whilst actually still having done stuff. The other reason this benefits long-term productivity besides helping you not get bored with your kind of larger goals is that it builds self-efficacy, probably our favorite term on the podcast.
从而体验到新奇事物带来的清爽和重要的力量。（你知道，三项杂务，两项小任务，看得见的进展。但它们也，你知道，它们也减少了很多琐碎的事情，它们给你带来进展。它们还清除了你可能一直在推迟的事情的杂物。然后一项大任务坐在中间。这意味着你在一天结束时确实有一种有意义的成就感，同时实际上还做成了事情。）除了帮你避免对更大的目标感到厌倦之外，它有益于长期生产力的另一个原因是它能建立自我效能感，这可能是我们在播客中最喜欢的术语。
The sense self-efficacy is the sense that we can meaningfully change outcomes through our actions, our own actions and behaviors. Small accomplishments are just as important as big accomplishments for self-efficacy because it gives us a daily reminder that mental, emotional, cognitive input, our input is creating physical output and progress, even on days when the big goal feels very, very far away, even on days when, you know, we don't have 12 hours to do stuff. It just makes you feel good. It makes you feel like, okay, at the end of the day, I have done my, oh my God, now I can't remember how many it is, six things. I've done my six things. I feel accomplished. I've done a little bit of everything. I'm good. I can rest now.
自我效能感是指通过我们的行动、我们自己的行动和行为有意义地改变结果的感觉。小的成就不亚于大的成就，对于自我效能感同样重要，因为它每天提醒我们，精神、情感、认知的输入，我们的输入正在创造身体上的输出和进展，即使在宏伟目标感觉非常非常遥远的那些日子里，即使在（你知道）我们没有 12 小时来做事日子里。它只是让你感觉良好。它让你觉得，好吧，在一天结束时，我已经完成了我的，天哪，现在我不记得是多少了，六件事。我已经完成了我的六件事。我感到很有成就感。我对每件事都做了一点点。我很好。我现在可以休息了。
Okay, tip number two, I think we've all heard the term like, eat the frog, right? This was always something my dad said to me when I was growing up, like eat the frog. Basically, always do the hard thing first. When you look at that list, the three, two, one list, the biggest thing, the most unpleasant, difficult, annoying thing, the thing you are most reluctant to do, the one that you are most likely to procrastinate on, that's the one you go for at the beginning. I think we have this tendency to think that we should ease ourselves into things or warm up for the day or warm up for the hard stuff. Obviously, like, if you're big task, like if you're exercising like a warm up, but don't leave the workout to the end of the day. Don't leave the most important email till 5pm. Don't leave the tiring conversation or the riding push till the point where you are exhausted.
好的，秘诀二，我想我们都听过“吃青蛙”这个词，对吧？我长大时我爸总是对我说这个，比如“吃青蛙”。基本上，永远先把困难的事情做了。当你看到那个清单，三二一清单时，最大的事情、最令人不快、最困难、最烦人的事情、你最不愿意做的事情、你最有可能拖延的事情，那就是你一开始就要去解决的事情。我认为我们有一种倾向，认为我们应该让自己轻松进入状态，或者为一天热身，或者为困难的事情热身。显然，就像，如果你的大任务，比如如果你在锻炼，就像热身一样，但不要把锻炼留到一天结束时。不要把最重要的邮件留到下午 5 点。不要把累人的对话或写作冲刺留到你筋疲力尽的时候。
Even if your motivation improves throughout the day, your focus probably doesn't. There is probably a specific time, likely when you first start, where you are going to have the most cognitive resources available. Not using those resources is avoidance. You're avoiding it. When you avoid the hard task, you get the momentary feeling of relief, the momentary feeling of hope, but surprise, surprise, the task is still there. It stays on your mind. It follows you throughout the day. it makes any break or sense of achievement like from other tasks it always feels like it's slightly contaminated because you're like yay i did that but oh that thing is still there like that thing i've been avoiding i still haven't done it until it's done the rest of the day feels half it feels like a
即使你的动力在一天中有所改善，你的注意力可能也不会。可能有一个特定的时间，很可能是你刚开始的时候，你拥有最多的可用认知资源。不使用这些资源就是逃避。你在逃避它。当你逃避困难的任务时，你会获得片刻的解脱感，片刻的希望感，但出乎意料的是，任务依然存在。它留在你的脑海里。它一整天都跟着你。它使得任何休息或来自其他任务的成就感总是感觉有点被污染了，因为你会想：耶，我做到了，但是哦，那件事还在那里，就像我一直逃避的那件事，我还没做呢。直到它做完，剩下的日子感觉都是一半的，感觉像是一个
distraction so before you give your brain the day to negotiate to rationalize to delay catastrophes overthink just decide to begin and begin is the key word here. Doing the hard thing first doesn't mean that it needs to be done perfectly. Doesn't mean you need to finish the whole hard thing at 8 a.m. It just means give your freshest, fullest attention to the task that would otherwise drain your emotional energy all day. And as we said, a lot of productivity is just emotional regulation, is just seeing the hard thing that's going to linger and pushing through it from like our one. To add to this, research is from New York University in a 2006 paper highlighted the concept of implementation intentions and this
干扰。所以在你给大脑一天时间去谈判、合理化、推迟灾难、过度思考之前，只需决定开始，“开始”这里是关键词。先把困难的事情做好并不意味着它需要完美完成。并不意味着你需要在早上 8 点完成所有的难事。这只意味着把你最新鲜、最全的注意力投入到那些否则会一整天消耗你情感能量的任务中。正如我们所说，很多生产力只是情绪调节，只是看到那个挥之不去的难事并从我们的一开始就坚持下去。除此之外，纽约大学 2006 年的一篇论文中的研究强调了实施意图（implementation intentions）的概念，这
plays a really important role for this tip. Basically, it's specific plans about when, where, and how you will act. They suggested using these implementation intentions for goals that you want to avoid because they significantly improve your chances of achieving them. In other words, if you build out how exactly you're going to go about doing something, you're more likely to do it. So instead of just, I'm going to work on this in the morning, if you say, okay, after breakfast, I'm going to sit at my desk and I'm going to write 300 words before checking my phone, that's going to be more effective. Like, that's going to be much better.
对这个技巧起着非常重要的作用。基本上，它是关于你何时、何地以及如何行动的具体计划。他们建议将这些实施意图用于你想要避免的目标，因为它们显著提高了你实现这些目标的几率。换句话说，如果你详细规划好你将如何着手做某事，你就更有可能去做它。所以与其只是说“我早上要处理这个”，不如说“早饭后，我要坐在桌前写 300 个字，然后才看手机”，这会更有效。这会好得多。
So yes, do the hard thing first, but also to cement this into action, define the hard thing clearly enough, to find it with a timestamp, define it with an endpoint, a progress point, a location, even, because it's harder to argue with a plan than a wish. I'll give you some other examples, just to help you out with this. Instead of saying,
所以，是的，先把困难的事情做好，但也要将其实际付诸行动，将难事定义得足够清晰，用时间戳来定义它，用终点、进展点甚至地点来定义它，因为与计划争辩比与愿望争辩要难。我再给你举几个例子，来帮你更好地理解这一点。与其说，
I'm going to sort my finances, try, you know, before I start anything else, I will open my banking app and make a list of every subscription service I'm paying for. Instead of, I'm going to work on my dissertation, try, okay, at 11 a.m., I'm going to have done these things, and I will go to the library, and I will write it to the first 300 rough words of my literature review. Instead of saying, I'm going to get my life together, try right after lunch.
“我要整理我的财务状况”，不如尝试：“在我开始其他事情之前，我要打开我的银行应用程序，列出我正在支付的所有订阅服务。”与其说“我要写我的论文”，不如尝试：“好的，上午 11 点，我已经完成了这些事情，我要去图书馆，把它写到我的文学评论的前 300 个草稿字。”与其说“我要把我的生活过好”，不如尝试：“午饭后，
I'm going to spend 25 minutes replying to emails that have been sitting in my inbox and going through all of my text messages from my parents and my family and just answer them. The hard thing becomes less threatening. the thing we procrastinate about the most becomes less threatening when it becomes concrete. A lot of productivity advice focuses on time management. We are focused on emotion management. Can you tolerate the discomfort of starting? Can you tolerate the task being imperfect?
我要花 25 分钟回复收件箱里的邮件，并查看来自我父母和家人的所有短信，然后回复他们。”困难的事情变得不那么具有威胁性了。我们拖延最多的事情，当它变得具体时，就会变得不那么具有威胁性。很多生产力建议都集中在时间管理上。我们专注于情绪管理。你能忍受开始时的不适吗？你能忍受任务不完美吗？
Can you act before you feel fully ready? What is going to make you feel more emotionally capable of starting right now? Think of doing the hard thing first. It's not about punishing yourself. it's about freeing yourself from the emotional burden and tax of avoidance that is going to follow you for the rest of the day if you don't just buy the bullet. Okay, let's take a short break here. Then we will return with a bunch more advice.
你能赶在你感觉完全准备好之前采取行动吗？是什么让你在当下感觉更有情感能力开始？想想先做困难的事情。这不是关于惩罚自己。而是关于让自己从逃避的情感负担和税赋中解脱出来，如果你不咬咬牙，那些情绪负担会一整天跟着你。好了，我们在这里稍作休息。然后我们将带着更多的建议回来。
Stay with us. I like to eat well, but after work, after errands, after everything else, cooking just doesn't happen. That's why I started using Factor. Factor delivers fresh, never frozen, ready to eat meals. Designed by dietitians for balanced nutrition that actually fits my life. No prep, no cleanup. Just heat, eat, and move on. And just like that, I get my time back. No dishes, no poor choices, no dinner stress.
请继续收听。我喜欢吃得好，但下班后、跑完腿、处理完其他一切之后，做饭根本就不现实。这就是为什么我开始使用 Factor。Factor 提供新鲜、从未冷冻、即食的餐食。由营养师设计，提供平衡的营养，真正适合我的生活。无需准备，无需清理。只需加热、享用，然后继续。就这样，我找回了时间。没有盘子，没有糟糕的选择，没有晚餐的压力。
I don't have to plan. And somehow, I'm still eating meals like grilled salmon, creamy shrimp pasta, and flavorful chicken bowls. Food that tastes like I worked for it, even though, well, I didn't. Factor helps me stay on track. High protein, low carb, no dairy, whatever the goal. Right now, get up to $90 off and free shipping. Hurry, this offer won't last long.
我不用做计划。不知何故，我依然能吃到烤三文鱼、奶油虾意面和美味的鸡肉饭碗这样的饭菜。尝起来像是我费了很大功夫做出来的食物，尽管，好吧，我并没有。Factor 帮我保持状态。高蛋白、低碳水、无乳制品，无论目标是什么。现在，最高可享 90 美元折扣并免运费。赶快行动吧，此优惠不会持续太久。
Go to FactorMeals.ca and use code easy. That's up to $90 off and free shipping, but only with the code easy at factormeals.ca. Factor. Canada's number one meal delivery service. You've heard the chaos. Now you can see it. Do we want to jump right in?
访问 FactorMeals.ca 并使用代码 easy。最高可享 90 美元折扣并免运费，但仅限在 factormeals.ca 使用代码 easy。Factor。加拿大排名第一的餐食配送服务。你听过那些混乱。现在你可以看到了。我们想直接跳进去吗？
Watch all your favorite podcasts from start to finish right inside the free IHard Radio app. Make some noise. Wooee! Catch every laugh and eye roll on shows like Bestie Listen, Hey Jonas and Las Culturistas. Now with full video. I'll just leave that there. It's the same hosts and the same chemistry with all the hilarious moments you've been missing right on your screen. Open the free IHard radio app.
在免费的 iHeart Radio App 中，从头到尾观看所有你喜欢的播客的完整视频。制造点动静！Wooee!在像 Bestie Listen、Hey Jonas 和 Las Culturistas 这样的节目中捕捉每一个笑声和白眼。现在有完整视频了。我就把话放这儿了。还是原来的主持人和原来的化学反应，那些你一直错过的爆笑时刻，直接在你的屏幕上呈现。打开免费的 iHeart Radio App。
Search video podcasts and tap watch. What's up fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from Together and I Heart Women's Sports. Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the first female solo rower to go from California to Hawaii.
搜索视频播客并点击观看。大家好！我是体育记者 Ari Chambers。嘿，你们好吗？我是你们的女孩 Sam J。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》的主持人，这是 Together 和 I Heart Women's Sports 的全新播客。因为说实话。女子体育这些天给我们提供了太多讨论的话题。所以 Kelsey Finler，她成为了第一位单人划船从加利福尼亚到夏威夷的女性。
My first thought is like, what's up with the snacks? Like, what are we eating? The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments that take over your entire timeline. And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week. Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka showing out, she beat Sabalinka. Shout out to you, Naomi. You get the palm, Naomi. You get the palm for that.
我的第一反应是，零食怎么样？比如，我们在吃什么？精彩集锦、竞争、新星、那些占据你整个时间线的时刻。还有那些在比赛期间开始、不知何故持续了一整周的对话。每周，我们都在剖析女子体育界最大的故事。Naomi Osaka 表现出色，她击败了 Sabalinka。向你致敬，Naomi。你拿到了棕榈叶，Naomi。你因此获得了棕榈叶。
Because we're not just interested in what happened. We're interested in why everyone's talking about it. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports on the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. You know us or rather you know them.
因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣。我们对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。因为每个人都在看女子体育。在 iHeartRadio App 收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。Apple Podcasts 或您获取播客的任何地方。嘿，Portlandia 的粉丝们。Carrie Brownstein 和 Fred Armisen 在这里。你们认识我们，或者更准确地说，你们认识他们。
Tony and Candid. Nina and Lance, Spike, and yes, The Chicken. We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast. Each week we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process.
Tony 和 Candid。Nina 和 Lance、Spike，当然还有 The Chicken。这些年来我们扮演了许多标志性的角色，但今天我们以我们自己的身份出现，向你们介绍 Podlandia, AEO rewatch，我们的全新播客。每周我们将从头开始重温一集的 Portlandia，剖析小品，探索我们最具标志性的角色的背景故事，重温你们熟悉和喜爱的 Portland 取景地，并敞开心扉谈论我们的创作过程。
How did any of this get made? Why do you think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song.
这一切是怎么拍出来的？你为什么觉得这是个好主意？我们准备好谈论它了。我们还将邀请那些帮助将其变为现实的人。客串明星、合作者和朋友，包括导演 Jonathan Chrysall、市长本人 Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐家 Amy Mann 等等。Kyle 在这里全力以赴。你完全是即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌。
Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. My first guest is Paris Hilton, Shakira, Luke and Yerrin, Samira and Gracie. I'm so excited on the bouncy bed. You have surprises?
嗯，我以为他会写。我以为你们都要写首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听 Podlandia。Ayo rewatch 在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或任何你获取播客的地方。我的第一位嘉宾是 Paris Hilton、Shakira、Luke 和 Yerrin、Samira 和 Gracie。我太兴奋了，在蹦床上。你有惊喜吗？
Many surprises. Welcome to Sweet 305 where the group chat comes to life. What up! It's like a way to say like, Oh, my friend, hello, my friend, oh, my brother. What a... Look, never I've ever been to have to have to be about. Except with my kids.
很多惊喜。欢迎来到 Sweet 305，群聊在此变为现实。什么情况！这就像是一种说法，哦，我的朋友，你好，我的朋友，哦，我的兄弟。什么……看，我从来没有去过、必须去过、关于过。除了和我的孩子们在一起。
My kids, if you know. Yes. Yes. C. My Amant. Oof. Punch. That's incredible.
我的孩子们，如果你懂的话。是的。是的。C. 我的 Amant。Oof。出拳。太不可思议了。
Yeah. You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. And no, there's someone that you'd like to collaborate. Like, I'd like to collaborate with this person. This is Sweet 305. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons as part of my Cultura podcast network on the IHartRadio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. So the third tip.
是的。你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。那是柠檬味的。不，有你想合作的人吗？比如，我想和这个人合作。这是 Sweet 305。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcast 或任何你获取播客的地方收听由 Lele Pons 主持的 Sweet 305，作为我的 Cultura 播客网络的一部分。所以第三个技巧。
maybe my favorite, so much so that I wrote about it in my book. Not once but twice. I literally wrote about it twice and I didn't even realize until after the book came out and somebody DM'd me and was like, okay, we get it. Give it a rest. Like you like this, you like this tip. Okay. And I was like, oops, didn't even realize I'd done it. But my third productivity hack is to stop copying somebody else's schedule and start studying your own rhythm. We are told the only way to be productive is to get up at 5 a.m. and journal and drink lemon water and work out and do all these things before you do eight hours of work and you should be totally switched on for those eight hours of work as well. And yeah, for some people the morning into the nine to five routine is where they feel most
可能是我最喜欢的，以至于我在书中写到了它。不仅一次，而是两次。我字面意思是写了两次，直到书出版后有人给我发私信说，好吧，我们懂了。歇会儿吧。就像你喜欢这个，你喜欢这个技巧。好吧。然后我说，哎呀，我甚至都没意识到我这么做了。但我的第三个生产力秘诀是停止模仿别人的时间表，开始研究你自己的节奏。我们被告知提高生产力的唯一方法是早上 5 点起床，写日记，喝柠檬水，锻炼，在做八小时的工作之前完成所有这些事情，而且在那八小时的工作中你也应该完全处于高度清醒状态。是的，对某些人来说，早上到“朝九晚五”的常规是他们感觉最
productive, but just because it's what's fed to us generally doesn't mean it works for everybody. It's this myth that just because something is normal must mean it's the best. For you, it might not be. This is where I want to introduce the idea of your chronotype. Your chronotype is basically your natural genetically determined preference for your sleep, wake timing. And that is, it reflects our circadian rhythm. It's just like the layer below.
有效率的时候，但仅仅因为这是通常灌输给我们的东西并不意味着它对每个人都管用。这是一种迷思，即某种东西正常就一定意味着它是最好的。对你来说，可能并非如此。在这里，我想引入你的睡眠型态（chronotype）的概念。你的睡眠型态基本上是你对睡眠-觉醒时间的天然基因决定的偏好。这反映了我们的昼夜节律。它就像是更深一层的东西。
There was a 2020 review in chronobiology that discussed how cognitive performance can be really affected by the interaction between the time of day that you are working and your individual chronotype. So whether you are a morning person, a night person, a midday person. And these findings have even been reflected more recently in 2025. They did another review. What this means is that people, you, may perform. differently depending on whether you are working in sync with your natural rhythm or not,
生物钟学领域在 2020 年有一篇综述，探讨了认知表现如何受到你工作的时间与你个人睡眠型态之间相互作用的深刻影响。所以无论你是早起型的人、夜猫子型的人，还是中午型的人。这些发现在 2025 年得到了更近期的反映。他们做了另一篇综述。这意味着人们（你）可能会根据你是否与你的自然节奏同步工作而表现出不同的效率，
it's not just dependent on discipline. You know, someone working at 6pm can be more productive than someone working at 9 a.m. But if your work only allows you to do work at 9 a.m. It must make you start at 9 a.m. Of course, you're going to feel lazy. You're not working in accordance with your chronotype. Same with like, you know, maybe your most productive hour is hours at like 1am to 5am. but if that is your natural rhythm, but if your system and your environment doesn't allow you to operate them,
这不仅仅取决于自律。你知道，下午 6 点工作的人可能比早上 9 点工作的人效率更高。但如果你的工作只允许你在早上 9 点工作，它必须让你在早上 9 点开始。当然，你会觉得自己很懒。你没有顺应你的睡眠型态工作。就像，也许你最高效的时间是凌晨 1 点到凌晨 5 点。但如果那是你的自然节奏，而你的系统和环境不允许你在那个时间运作，
you're not going to be as productive. Knowing this, you need to work to figure out what this may be for you. Because you might be constantly sabotaging yourself by scheduling hard work for a time of day when your brain has already checked out. I know I said swallow the frog. But if the best time to swallow the frog is at 7pm and instead of 9 a.m., you should be working at 7 p.m. Some ways of identifying your chronotype, what sleep pattern, sleep weight pattern, I should say, do you typically follow on holidays or when you don't have to work? When does your body naturally feel sleepy?
你的效率就不会那么高。了解这一点后，你需要努力弄清楚这对你意味着什么。因为你可能一直在通过将高强度的工作安排在你的大脑已经关机的一天中的某个时间来不断自我 sabotage（自我破坏）。我知道我说过“吞下青蛙”。但如果吞下青蛙的最佳时间是晚上 7 点而不是早上 9 点，你应该在晚上 7 点工作。识别你的睡眠型态的一些方法：你在假期或不用工作时通常遵循什么睡眠模式、睡眠-觉醒模式？你的身体自然在什么时候感到困倦？
When does it naturally feel alert? When do you feel your sharpest? When do you get most easily distracted? When do you feel most creative or in a state of flow? When do you feel most excited by admin tasks? as you go along, you can kind of match your rhythm to your natural energy levels. And I know this isn't possible for everybody. I know it's so difficult when you do work a nine to five or you do work shift work, but try and schedule, try as much as you can to even match your kind of daily life
它自然在什么时候感到警觉？你什么时候感觉思路最敏捷？你什么时候最容易分心？你什么时候感觉最有创意或处于心流状态？你什么时候对行政任务感到最兴奋？随着时间的推移，你可以将你的节奏与你的自然能量水平相匹配。我知道这并不适合所有人。我知道当你确实做着朝九晚五的工作或轮班工作时这有多么困难，但请尝试安排，尽可能多地尝试将你的日常生活也与此相匹配。
to this as well. I know my chronotype is like, I actually don't know what the name for it is, but it's like 3D7 and then 9 till midnight. when I am like, no, I'm going to be most alert, which is at like 6pm or later, that's when I do all my planning, all my editing, all my high energy things. My low energy window, which is normally like in the morning kind of, is like when I focus on more shallow tasks like formatting, tidying, basic admin, still things that need to be done, but not things that require like deep, deep thinking. this is the thing about productivity, the most productive people are actually probably some of the most self-aware mentally because they know that abiding by what everybody else is telling them to do
我知道我的睡眠型态是，我其实不知道它的名字是什么，但它是 3D7，然后是 9 点到午夜。当我处于“不，我要保持最高警觉，也就是傍晚 6 点或更晚”的状态时，那正是我做所有规划、所有剪辑、所有高能量事情的时候。我的低能量窗口通常在早晨左右，是我专注于更浅层任务的时候，比如格式化、整理、基础行政工作，这些仍然是需要完成的事情，但不是那些需要深度思考的事情。这就是生产力的关键所在，最高产的人实际上可能是心理自我觉察能力最强的人，因为他们知道盲目遵循其他所有人告诉他们该做的事
and how their day should operate isn't going to work for them. They stagger their workload and work when works best for them. Obviously it's also a lifestyle thing. So we're not going to say like, oh, these people who don't work a nine to five must be the most emotionally aware because they can work whenever they want. No, it's just that I think people who understand that and understand the role that their chronotype plays, which is not 100%, but it is a large, a large factor, are able to be more productive, both within and outside of a typical work structure. Because even if you have a nine to five, your chronotype is still going to be active, like your chronotype window is still going to be active for some part of that. I'm just saying it might not be
以及他们的日程应该如何运作并不适合他们。他们错开工作量，在最适合他们的时候工作。显然这也是一种生活方式的事情。所以我们不会说，哦，这些不进行朝九晚五工作的人一定是最具情绪觉察力的人，因为他们可以随时随地工作。不，只是我认为那些理解这一点并理解他们的睡眠型态所扮演的角色的（虽然不是 100%，但它是一个很大、很大的因素）人，能够在典型的结构之内和之外都更具生产力。因为即使你从事朝九晚五的工作，你的睡眠型态仍然会活跃，比如你的睡眠型态窗口在那段时间的某些部分仍然会活跃。我只是说可能不是
9 a.m. when everybody expects you to do all the hard work. It might be like 5 or 6 p.m. And so how can you think about your day that maximizes that peak productivity window best for you? Okay, tip number four is habit stacking. And it is one I added to this list specifically for the boring things. Habit stacking. At its moment online, a few years ago after James Clear, the author of Atomic Habits, made it very, very popular, made it go, I guess, viral. I don't know if it was viral, but everybody seems to know it. It is when you attach a new behavior to an existing cue you already have. So, after I brush my teeth, I take my vitamins. They're in the same place, same time.
每个人都期望你做所有苦差事的早上 9 点。可能是下午 5 点或 6 点。所以你如何思考你的一天，才能最好地最大化对你而言的那个生产力高峰窗口？好的，秘诀四是习惯堆叠（habit stacking）。这是我专门为那些无聊的事情添加到这个清单中的一个。习惯堆叠。几年前，在《原子习惯》的作者 James Clear 让它变得非常非常受欢迎、让它走红（我不知道它算不算病毒式传播，但每个人似乎都知道它）之后，它在网络上火了一阵。它是指当你将一个新的行为附加到一个你已经拥有的现有线索上。例如：在我刷完牙后，我吃维生素。它们在同一个地方，同一时间。
And after I finish, I don't know, brushing my teeth, I automatically wash my face. Whilst I make my coffee, I am going to write my to-do list. The same habits are paired up every day. Whilst I drive to work, I call somebody in my life who I need to catch up with. Like, every single day, those two things, something that I know I'm always going to do, is paired with something that I really want to do, that I know is important that I know I'm finding hard. and finding it hard to do. There was a 2010 study published in the European Journal of Social Psychology
等我刷完牙之后，我不知道，我就会自动去洗脸。在我煮咖啡的时候，我会写下我的待办事项清单。每天都是同样的习惯相互搭配。当我开车去上班时，我会给生活中的某个人打电话，一个我需要叙叙旧的人。就像每天一样，这两件事——一件我知道我总是会做的事，与一件我真的很想做的事搭配在一起，我知道这件事很重要，但我发现它很难，而且觉得很难做到。2010年，《欧洲社会心理学杂志》上曾发表过一项研究
that looked into the science behind habit stacking. They had 96 participants to choose an activity behavior to carry out daily, so basically a chore to carry out daily in the same context for 12 weeks. They found that when participants paired that behavior with something that was already happening, the time it took for that behavior to reach a level of automaticity. So basically, this is the highest level of habit formation where you don't actually even have to think consciously about doing something. You just do it.
探讨了习惯叠加背后的科学原理。他们让96名参与者选择一项日常进行的活动行为，基本上就是每天在相同的环境下进行一项琐事，持续12周。他们发现，当参与者将该行为与已经在发生的事情结合起来时，该行为达到自动化水平所需的时间就会缩短。也就是说，这是习惯形成的最高阶段，你甚至不需要有意识地去思考做某件事。你只是顺其自然地去做。
The more people who paired, like if you were somebody who paired the new behavior with an old behavior, you got to that level of automatic processing and automatic habit, stacking automatic habit processing much faster. A further 2019 paper from researchers at the University of Bath actually suggested that habits rather than intentions or goals are the vehicles for self-control because they reduce the need to constantly deliberate and decide. A goal is kind of something you have to decide on every day. A habit is not. This is exactly why meal prepping, gym plans, automatically saving sums of money, those kind of goals are so effective because a habit is something that
那些将新行为与旧行为进行搭配的人，会更快地达到那种自动加工和自动习惯、习惯叠加自动加工的水平。巴斯大学的研究人员在2019年发表的一篇论文实际上表明，习惯（而不是意图或目标）才是实现自我控制的工具，因为它们减少了不断思考和做决定的需要。目标可以说是你每天必须做出决定的东西，而习惯则不然。这正是为什么备餐、健身计划、自动存钱这类目标如此有效，因为习惯是一种
reduces choice. And when we have to make less choices, that is when we are our most productive because the cognitive friction of having to decide every single day, am I going to do this or this or this or this in pursuit of my goal is removed? The goals should not inform your habits every single day. Your habits should be the thing that is the basis for your goal. Next, I think it's number five. Are you up to number five? I always get off track when I do these list episodes, but get rid of of all or nothing thinking. I've been very guilty of thinking, well, you know, I don't have an hour to go to the gym today, so I'm just not going to bother. Or, you know, I know I'm going to be drinking at my friend's birthday. So why not drink on Thursday and Friday as well? But this kind of
能减少选择的东西。当我们需要做出的选择变少时，正是我们最具生产力的时候，因为消除了为了追求目标而每天必须纠结“我是做这个、这个、这个还是那个”所带来的认知摩擦。目标不应该指导你每天的习惯。你的习惯应该成为你目标的基础。接下来，我想这是第五点。你讲到第五点了吗？每当我做这种盘点类单集的节目时，总是会跑题，但我们要摆脱全盘否定或非黑即白的思维。我非常容易有这种想法：好吧，你知道，我今天没有一个小时去健身房，所以我索性就不去了。或者，你知道，我今晚要在朋友的生日上喝酒。那么为什么周四和周五不也喝一杯呢？但这种
thinking eliminates the minor progress that builds into major progress. I think one of the biggest traps we fall into with productivity is waiting for the perfect time, waiting for the perfect environment, waiting for the perfect moment and equation and for everything to go right in order to act because we want to give ourselves the greatest chance of success. You know, we tell ourselves, well, if I'm going to work out, I may as well, I need to have the full hour so I do it perfectly. If I'm going to clean the house, I have to have the whole afternoon because I don't want to do it half-assed. I'm going to sort out my emails the next time I can sit down and really give them my full attention. I'll start writing that book when I really have the perfect quiet morning. I'm in the
想法会抹杀那些积少成多、汇聚成重大进步的小小进展。我认为我们在追求生产力时陷入的最大陷阱之一，就是等待完美的时机、等待完美的坏境、等待完美的时刻和公式，以及等待一切顺利进行才去采取行动，因为我们想给自己最大的成功机会。你知道，我们会对自己说，好吧，如果我要锻炼，我最好、我需要有一个完整的小时，这样我才能做得完美。如果我要打扫房子，我必须花整个下午的时间，因为我不想敷衍了事。下一次当我能坐下来并真正全神贯注时，我再去整理我的电子邮件。等我真正有一个完美的安静早晨时，我再开始写那本书。我有
right mood. The desk is clear. The sunshine was great. But then life is always going to be too busy for that. Life is never going to give you perfect conditions. And so we do nothing and we blame the conditions not being perfect and not ourselves for operating regardless. The other thing is, If we know we have that extra time unfilled, that 20 minutes, 10 minutes, 15 minutes, the other work we need to do or procrastination is always going to end up filling that time. Anyways, this links really nicely to something called Parkinson's Law. Parkinson's Law is not about the disease. It comes from the British historian Cyril Northgate Parkinson.
合适的心情。桌子很干净。阳光很好。但生活总是会为此而忙得不可开交。生活永远不会给你提供完美的条件。所以我们什么都不做，然后把原因归咎于条件不够完美，而不是责怪自己没有无论如何都去坚持。另一件事是，如果我们知道自己还有额外的空闲时间，那20分钟、10分钟、15分钟，我们需要做的其他工作或拖延症总是会最终填满这段时间。无论如何，这与一个叫做“帕金森定律”的概念完美契合。帕金森定律与疾病无关。它源于英国历史学家西里尔·诺思科特·帕金森。
And he introduced this idea in an essay he wrote in the 1950s in the economist, where he basically said, work expands so as to fill the time available for its completion. He was kind of writing satirically, actually, when he wrote this essay, he was talking about how, like, he was actually talking about the political system and, like, the public service system and how these administrative systems can grow and create more work for themselves, even when the actual workload does not increase. But it applies to my life, it applies to your life as well. If you give yourself all day to clean your house, the task is going to take all day.
他在20世纪50年代为《经济学人》撰写的一篇文章中提出了这个观点，他基本上指出：工作会自动膨胀，占满所有可用于完成它的时间。事实上，他在写这篇文章时带有讽刺意味，他当时谈论的是政治体制和服务系统，以及这些行政系统是如何膨胀并为自己创造更多工作的，即便实际工作量并没有增加。但这同样适用于我的生活，也适用于你的生活。如果你给自己一整天的时间来打扫房间，这项任务就会花掉一整天。
But if you give yourself 30 minutes, you're probably going to get a lot more done. If you give yourself three hours at the gym, chances are you're probably going to do about as much exercising as you would only do if you had 45 minutes. Do you see what I mean? Like the task expands to kind of fill the time we give it. Like, there is a sprawl. Parkinson's Law gives language to that sprawl. You need to stop giving yourself such big containers to act in or so much space to act with. Now, I have to say, this is a psychology podcast. Parkinson's Law did not begin as a psychological theory about personal productivity, but I think we can take a lot from this idea because it captures something many of us
但如果你只给自己30分钟，你可能会完成更多的工作。如果你给自己三个小时在健身房，你可能做的大部分锻炼其实和你只有45分钟时做的差不多。你明白我的意思吗？任务会膨胀，以此来填满我们给它的时间。就像会有蔓延的趋势一样。帕金森定律为这种蔓延赋予了概念。你必须停止给自己留出那么大的行动空间，或者留出那么多的时间来做事。现在，我必须说，这是一个心理学播客。帕金森定律并非作为关于个人生产力的心理学理论诞生的，但我认为我们可以从这个概念中汲取很多东西，因为它捕捉到了我们许多人在日常生活中
recognize in our everyday life, which is that we often overestimate how much time things are going to take, and we underestimate how well we will rise to the occasion. But also, we forget that, I think on top of that, we forget that when we have less time, we will push and we will be more productive in that case as well. The problem isn't that we have no time, is that we dismiss the time we do have because it doesn't feel ideal and we kind of also self-sabotaged and think we're less capable. If you only have 20 minutes, 20 minutes compared to zero is already better, even if it's not an hour. What happens if you do two 20-minute workouts, let's say, every two weeks? That's 140 minutes. You know, seven days a week, if you just did 20 minutes compared to
都能认同的一点，那就是：我们经常高估事情需要花费的时间，而低估了我们应对挑战的能力。但同时我们也忘记了——我认为最重要的是——我们忘记了当时间减少时，我们会去拼搏，在那种情况下我们也会更有生产力。问题不在于我们没有时间，而在于我们因为感觉不够理想而轻视了我们确实拥有的时间，并且我们还会自我怀疑，觉得自己能力不足。如果你只有20分钟，哪怕不是一个小时，20分钟总比零要好。假设你每两周做两次20分钟的锻炼，会发生什么？那是140分钟。一周七天，如果你哪怕只做20分钟，也总比
still zero. Your all or nothing thinking is keeping you from the power of cumulative or compound growth, right? Respect the time you have, even if you believe it's not enough. Respect your capacity to actually work your butt off and to be motivated and to be inspired by urgency. Okay, I realize I total of it because I said tip number four was my favorite. That's a lie. This one here is my favorite tip, most certainly. And it's probably my most personally relevant tip I'm going to give you guys on this list. If you watched our last episode, I think, on Netflix with Grace Beverly, you'll know I spoke about how I've been doing something that doesn't sound particularly productive, but is. And that has been that I've been sending off the most outlandish emails to the most insanely out of reach people asking them
什么都不做要强。你的非黑即白思维阻碍了你获得累积或复合增长的力量，对吧？尊重你拥有的时间，即使你认为它还不够。尊重你真正全力以赴、充满动力并被紧迫感所激励的能力。好吧，我发现我彻底说错了，因为我曾说过第四个技巧是我的最爱。那是谎言。这个绝对是我最喜欢的技巧，毫无疑问。这很可能也是我在这份清单中给你们的、与我个人最相关的技巧。如果你看了我们上一集和格蕾丝·贝弗利的Netflix节目，你就会知道我谈到了我一直在做的一件听起来不怎么有生产力、但其实很有成效的事。那就是我一直在向那些极其高不可攀的人发送最离谱的电子邮件，邀请他们
to be guests on the psychology of your 20s. The example I gave was Simone Biles and I talked about how she was like one of the only people to say no instead of just say nothing. This may not sound relevant but the reason I've been doing this is part of something that I've been calling shoot your shot Wednesdays. Shoot your shot Wednesdays is where every Wednesday I dedicate two hours of my day to just testing my luck. Every week I will like send out some of the most insane Hail Mary emails. I reach out to like the most amazing people who are probably never going to see it. I like blindly ask for things. I reach out to brands. I pitch articles because why not? Why not like you don't ask? And the answer is no. I'm really just trying to increase my surface area for luck. And although that
来做《你二十岁的心理学》的嘉宾。我给出的例子是西蒙·拜尔斯，我谈到她是少数几个回复“不”而不是直接不回复的人之一。这听起来可能不太相关，但我这么做的原因是我一直在做的一件事，我称之为“放手一搏星期三”。“放手一搏星期三”是指每周三我都拿出一天中的两个小时来碰碰运气。每周我都会发出一些最疯狂、像“孤注一掷”一样的电子邮件。我联系那些可能永远不会看到邮件的超级大牛。我盲目地提出请求。我联系品牌方。我毛遂自荐写文章，因为为什么不呢？为什么不呢，你不问的话，
may sound spontaneous, it is still productive. This is why I believe this tip deserves its place on this list, even if it is a bit atypical. As well as clearing tasks, getting work done, productivity also deserves a reframe in that it creates possibility. I don't think we should just be using it for things that are boring or things that are a slog. I think it should be utilized for expanding as well. You might have a perfectly organized inbox. You might complete every small task that is required of you every day, but still be no closer to the life that you really crave because your productivity doesn't also include audacity. The psychology here is really around agency. And if we revisit that self-efficacy theory, again, self-efficacy is our belief that we
起来很随性，但它依然很有生产力。这就是为什么我认为这个技巧值得在这份清单中占有一席之地，哪怕它有点非同寻常。除了清理任务、完成工作之外，生产力也需要被重新定义，因为它创造了可能性。我认为我们不应该只将它用于那些无聊的事情或繁重的工作。我认为它也应该被用来实现拓展。你可能拥有一个完美整理收件箱。你可能完成了每天要求你做的每一项小任务，但依然离你真正渴望的生活毫无更近一步，因为你的生产力中并不包含魄力。这里的心理学实际上是围绕着能动性展开的。如果我们再次回顾自我效能理论，自我效能就是我们相信自己
can change an outcome. And our belief is built partly through our confidence and our mastery of experiences. So moments like this where we say, hey, I really want something. I'm responsible for that. I'm not going to wait for somebody else to give it to me. I'm going to go out and get it. Like, I'm going to open myself up to the opportunity because who's to say the answer is going to be no. I'm just, I'm open to the next great opportunity that comes along. I'm producing those opportunities for myself, right? I'm being productive in a way that may not seem structured and organized, but is definitely worthy of output. I would highly, highly recommend carving out space in your week for this. It doesn't have to be a full day. For me, sometimes it's just an hour or two
答案就是“不”。我真的只是在增加我遇到好运的概率。尽管这听
where it is something that I have on my agenda constantly. I'm going to push, my luck. I'm going to see how far opportunities can take me. I'm going to see how far just asking for something can take me. And to me, that is a productive endeavor. Okay, we're going to take one more short break, I know, but we'll be right back very, very soon. I like to eat well. But after work, after errands, after everything else, cooking just doesn't happen. That's why I started using Factor. Factor delivers fresh, never frozen, ready to eat meals. designed by dietitians for balanced nutrition that actually fits my life. No prep, no cleanup.
这始终在我的日程安排中。我会去争取机会，看机遇能带我走多远，看仅仅开口请求能带我走多远。对我来说，这是一项富有成效的努力。好的，我们要再做一个短暂的休息，我知道，但我们很快就会回来。我喜欢吃得好。但在下班后、办完琐事后、处理完其他一切之后，做饭根本无法实现。这就是我开始使用Factor的原因。Factor提供新鲜、从未冷冻、即食的餐食，由营养师设计，提供符合我生活实际的均衡营养。无需备料，无需清理。
Just heat, eat, and move on. And just like that, I get my time back. No dishes, no poor choices, no dinner stress. I don't have to plan. And somehow, I'm still eating meals like grilled salmon, creamy shrimp pasta, and flavorful chicken bowls. Food that tastes like I worked for it, even though, well, I didn't. Factor helps me stay on track.
只需加热、食用，然后继续。就这样，我找回了自己的时间。没有盘子要洗，没有糟糕的选择，没有晚餐的压力。我不需要计划。而且不知何故，我依然能吃到诸如烤三文鱼、奶油虾仁意面和风味鸡肉碗之类的餐食。吃起来就像是我自己费力做的一样，尽管，嗯，我并没有。Factor帮助我保持正轨。
High protein, low carb, no dairy, whatever the goal. Right now, get up to $90 off and free shipping. Hurry, this offer won't last long. Go to FactorMeals.ca and use code easy. That's up to $90 off and free shipping, but only with the code easy at Factormeals.ca. Factor. Canada's number one meal delivery service.
高蛋白、低碳水、无乳糖，无论目标是什么。现在，最高可享90美元优惠并免运费。赶快行动，此优惠不会持续太久。访问 FactorMeals.ca 并使用代码 easy。最高可优惠90美元并免运费，但仅限在 Factormeals.ca 使用代码 easy。Factor。加拿大排名第一的餐食配送服务。
You've heard the chaos. Now you can see it. Do we want to jump right in? Watch all your favorite podcasts from start to finish, right inside the free IHard Radio app. Make some noise. Catch every laugh and eye roll On shows like Bestie Listen
你已经听过了那种混乱。现在你可以看到了。我们想直接开始吗？在免费的 IHeart Radio 应用内，从头到尾观看所有你最喜欢的播客。发出点声音。捕捉每一个笑声和白眼，在诸如 Bestie Listen 的节目中。
Hey Jonas and Las Coltracias Now with full video It's the same hosts and the same chemistry With all the hilarious moments you've been missing Right on your screen Open the free IHard Radio app Search video podcasts and tap watch What's up fam? I'm sports journalist Ari Chambers
嘿 Jonas 和 Las Coltracias，现在有了完整视频！还是那些主持人，还是那种默契，带着你一直以来错过的所有爆笑瞬间，直接在你的屏幕上呈现。打开免费的 IHeart Radio 应用，搜索视频播客并点击观看。最近怎么样，家人们？我是体育记者 Ari Chambers。
Hey what's up y'all? It's your girl Sam J And we're the host of everyone watches women's sports A New Podcast from Together and IHart Women's Sports Because let's be real. Women's sports is giving us way too much to talk about these days. So Kelsey Finler, she became the first female solo rower to go from California to Hawaii. My first thought is like, what's up with the snacks? Like, what are we eating? The highlights, the rivalries, the breakout stars, the moments that take over your entire timeline. And the conversations that start during the game and somehow keep going all week.
嘿，大家最近怎么样？我是你们的女孩 Sam J，我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》的主持人，这是一档来自 Together 和 IHart Women's Sports 的全新播客。说实话，女子体育现在给我们提供了太多可以谈论的话题。比如 Kelsey Finler，她成为了第一位单人从加利福尼亚划船到夏威夷的女性划船手。我的第一反应是：零食怎么办？我们在吃什么？精彩集锦、宿敌对决、突起的明星、占据你整个时间线的时刻，以及在比赛期间开始却不知为何能整整讨论一周的对话。
Every week, we're breaking down the biggest stories across women's sports. Naomi Osaka showing out She beat Sabalinka Shout out to you Naomi You get the palm Naomi! You get the palm for that
每周，我们都在剖析女子体育界最大的新闻。大阪直美大放异彩，她击败了萨巴伦卡。向你致敬，大阪直美！你得到了棕榈！你因为这个得到了棕榈！
Because we're not just interested in what happened We're interested in why everyone's talking about it Because everyone watches women's sports Listen to everyone watches women's sports On the IHeart Radio app Apple Podcast
因为我们不仅对发生了什么感兴趣，我们还对为什么每个人都在谈论它感兴趣。因为每个人都在看女子体育。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。
Or wherever you get your podcast Hey Portlandia fans Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen You know us or rather you know them Tony and Candice Nina and Lance Spike and yes the chicken We've played a lot of iconic characters over the years, but today we're showing up as ourselves to tell you about Podlandia, AEO rewatch, our brand new podcast.
或者无论你在哪里收听播客。嘿，Portlandia 的粉丝们，Carrie Brownstein 和 Fred Armisen，你们认识我们，或者更准确地说，你们认识他们：Tony 和 Candice、Nina 和 Lance、Spike，还有当然，那只鸡。我们多年来扮演过许多标志性的角色，但今天我们以自己的身份出现，来向你们介绍 Podlandia，一档重温节目，我们的全新播客。
Each week, we'll revisit an episode of Portlandia from the very beginning, breaking down the sketches, exploring the backstories of our most iconic characters, revisiting the Portland locations you know and love, and opening up about our creative process. How did any of this get made? Why do you think that was a good idea? We're ready to talk about it. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chryssel, the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song, a melody.
每周，我们都会从头开始重温一集 Portlandia，剖析短剧，探索我们最具标志性角色的背景故事，重温你们熟悉和喜爱的波特兰外景地，并敞开心扉谈论我们的创作过程。这一切是怎么拍出来的？你为什么觉得那是个好主意？我们准备好聊聊了。而且帮助我们将这一切变为现实的人们也会加入我们，包括客串明星、合作者和朋友，其中包括导演 Jonathan Chryssel、市长本人 Kyle McLaughlin、传奇音乐人 Amy Mann 等等。Kyle 在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴发挥，不仅是台词，还有一首歌、一段旋律。
Well, I thought he was going to write. I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia. Ayo rewatch on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. My first guest is Peres Hilton Shakira, Luke and Yerin Samira and Gracie I'm so excited
嗯，我以为他会写。我以为你们都会写一首歌。我记得你这么想过。收听 Podlandia。在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方重温 Ayo。我的第一位嘉宾是 Peres Hilton、夏奇拉、卢克和 Yerin、萨米拉和格雷西。我太兴奋了。
on the bouncy bed You have surprises Many surprises Welcome to Sweet 305 Where the group chat comes to life What up! It's like a way It's a way friend, hello
在弹跳床上，你有惊喜，许多惊喜。欢迎来到 Sweet 305，群聊在这里变为现实。嘛！就像一条路，一条朋友之路，你好。
My God, hello, hello Myrana Look, look, never I've Never I've ever seen With my kids Except with my kids, my kids you know. Se my
天哪，你好，你好，Myrana。看，看，从来没有，我从来没见过，和我的孩子一起，除了我的孩子，你知道的我的孩子。Se my
Amanté Uff That's incredible! Yeah, the only person I know that loves
Amanté Uff 太不可思议了！是的，我认识的唯一一个喜欢
a yellow Starburst It's lemonade And there someone You say I'd like to collaborate
黄色星爆糖的人是柠檬味的。然后有人说我想和这个人合作
with this person This is Sweet 305 Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons as part of
这个人是 Sweet 305。收听由 Lele Pons 主持的 Sweet 305，作为
my Cultura Podcast Network on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast or wherever
我的 Cultura 播客网络的一部分，在 IHeart Radio 应用、Apple Podcasts 或无论
you get your podcasts As we near the end of this episode, I have one final surprising piece of psychological advice for you. If you are looking to build that productivity muscle, that emotional productivity muscle, I'm going to introduce this with an analogy. Have you ever seen those gym bro videos from like the toughest, strongest, like men and women in the world, giving their exact routine?
你获取播客的地方。随着本集接近尾声，我最后要给你一个令人惊讶的心理学建议。如果你正在寻找建立那种生产力肌肉、那种情感生产力肌肉的方法，我将用一个类比来引入这一点。你有没有看过那些来自世界上最强悍、最强壮的男男女女的健身兄弟视频，分享他们确切的日常？
These people can like crush cars. I don't, like, I don't even know what they're capable of. like so strong. I don't know. Maybe it's just my algorithm. I will occasionally get these videos and I'll watch them because I want to be able to crush a car. But something they always incorporate in their routines that I've begun to notice is rest. It's like a huge part of how they grow is how they rest. Now before you stop listening here because I feel like you know where I'm going to take this, I need to make my argument for why you should be pausing and stepping away from work more than you probably are for at least an hour or two every single day.
这些人能压碎汽车。我不知道，我甚至不知道他们能做什么。太强了。我不知道。也许这只是我的算法。我偶尔会看到这些视频，我会看它们，因为我想能够压碎一辆汽车。但他们日常生活中总是包含的一点，我开始注意到的是休息。就像他们如何成长的很大一部分在于他们如何休息。现在，在你停止收听之前，因为我觉得你知道我要把这个带向何方，我需要阐述我的论点，说明为什么你应该比现在更多地暂停和远离工作，每天至少花一两个小时。
And I need you to be as serious about your unproductive downtime as your productive uptime. Similar to that all or nothing fallacy we end up in, we also end up in a rest is either optional or a distraction mindset. And we kind of half-ass our rest. we don't fully dedicate ourselves to having time off or to switching off. And by not doing that, we don't realize the insanely positive consequences of this for regular productivity. An article published by Berkeley in 2017, I was reading about just recently, was speaking about how even in our brain's resting state, when we are not directly focused on a task, our brain is still active. It is engaging its default network to plug away at problems,
我需要你对非生产性的休息时间像对生产性的工作时间一样认真。类似于我们最终陷入的非此即彼的谬误，我们最终也陷入了“休息要么是可选的，要么是一种分心”的心态。我们有点敷衍了事地休息，我们并没有全身心地投入到休假或关闭工作中。通过不这样做，我们没有意识到这对定期生产力带来的疯狂积极后果。伯克利于2017年发表的一篇文章，我最近刚刚读到，谈到即使在我们大脑的休息状态下，当我们没有直接专注于某项任务时，我们的大脑仍然很活跃。它正在调动其默认网络来钻研问题，
examine and toss out possible answers, discard others, look for new information. We may not be able to control these processes completely, but by learning to rest better, we support them. We support the secondary kind of work our brain can only do when we are calm. We let our brain do the automatic stuff. If you're constantly working, that doesn't happen. Additionally, when we rest and when you're intentional about rest, it replenishes what was previously depleted by hard work, things like our attention, our focus reserves, even our eyes' ability to direct themselves, our body's ability to calm itself, our capacity for divergent thinking. This is what this means for you, when you're not working, when you're taking a break, you need to be as present in the
检查并抛弃可能的答案，丢弃其他答案，寻找新信息。我们可能无法完全控制这些过程，但通过学习更好地休息，我们支持了它们。我们支持大脑只有在我们平静时才能进行的第二种工作。我们让大脑做自动的事情。如果你一直在工作，那就不会发生。此外，当我们休息时，当你刻意休息时，它会补充之前因繁重工作而耗尽的东西，比如我们的注意力、专注力储备，甚至眼睛引导自身的能力、身体平静自身的能力、发散思维的能力。这对你意味着什么，当你不在工作时，当你休息时，你需要像身处工作中一样融入到
break as you are present in the work. Often, you know, we're not fully working, but we're not fully resting either. We kind of sit down to relax, but we like keep scanning for like, what else we should be doing. You know, we're meant to be replying to messages from friends and then suddenly we're also refreshing our email. We're like, we've told ourselves that you're going to sit and read a book and and suddenly now you're half answering the messages. Like we take a break, but we feel guilty the whole time. So we're like doing 25% of a task at any given moment. That is not a productive way of being.
休息中。通常，你知道，我们没有完全工作，但我们也没有完全休息。我们坐下来放松，但我们一直在扫描还有什么我们应该做的事。你知道，我们本该回复朋友的消息，然后突然我们也在刷新电子邮件。我们告诉自己你要坐下来看书，然后突然间你又开始半心半意地回复消息。就像我们休息了，但我们整个过程都感到内疚。所以我们在任何特定时刻都在做25%的任务。那不是一种富有成效的生活方式。
You need to be able to mode switch. When you're in work mode, you're in it. When you're in relaxation mode, you're in that as well. Staying in the middle ground where you're like, I really deserve a break, but I don't deserve a break. I have to work. I really should be working, but I haven't given myself a break, so I should have a break. It just waste more of your time. Now, is there a right way to rest? Yes, I'm very
你需要能够切换模式。当你在工作模式时，你就全身心投入。当你在放松模式时，你也是如此。停留在中间地带，比如“我真的配得上休息，但我又不配休息，我必须工作，我真的应该工作，但我没有给自己放假，所以我应该休息”，只会浪费你更多的时间。现在，有没有正确的休息方式？是的，我很高兴
glad you asked. The author, what's her name? Sandra Dalton Smith, she did a really famous TED Talk in which she identified seven types of rest that we need to be hitting across the week to be productive. These are physical rest, emotional rest, spiritual rest, mental, social and sensory. Sounds like a lot of things, you often tick them off at the same time. The most important one, though, that she says is also the most neglected, is psychological rest. Authors of 2007 paper, I think it was published in the Journal of Occupational Health Psychology, identified that to truly recover from work stress and to be able to be productive day in and day out, yes, we need to engage in relaxation, Yes, we need to see our friends, of course.
你问了这个问题。这位作者，她叫什么名字？桑德拉·道尔顿·史密斯（Sandra Dalton Smith），她做了一场非常著名的TED演讲，在演讲中她指出了我们需要在全周达到的七种休息类型，以保持生产力。这些是身体休息、情感休息、精神休息、心理、社交和感官休息。听起来很多事情，你经常同时勾选它们。然而，她说最重要的一点也是最被忽视的一点，就是心理休息。2007年一篇论文的作者，我想它发表在《职业健康心理学杂志》上，指出要真正从工作压力中恢复过来并能够日复一日地保持生产力，是的，我们需要参与放松，是的，我们需要见朋友，当然。
But most important for recovery, cognitively and mentally, is psychological detachment. So being able to put emotional distance between you and a task, having a sense of closure to the work or to the productive day. Just physically relaxing is not enough, which sounds like a bummer because it's like, wow, we're already doing so much. But even if you stop working physically, sometimes your mind lingers. mentally. So you need to have some kind of ritual, some kind of interruptor, some kind of pattern shift or mode shift that can say, we're not doing that anymore. I am out of that zone. I am in this zone now. And I know that in order to be the most productive when I'm in the zone from before, I need to be all here. Like, I need to be mentally disengaged from work. And it's not helping me
但在认知和精神上恢复最重要的是心理疏离。所以能够在你和任务之间保持情感上的距离，对工作或富有成效的一天有一种结束感。仅仅身体放松是不够的，这听起来像是一件令人沮丧的事，因为感觉就像，哇，我们已经做了这么多了。但即使你停止了身体上的工作，有时你的思绪仍会流连忘返。在精神上。所以你需要某种仪式，某种打断器，某种模式转变或模式转换，可以说，我们不再做那个了。我已经走出了那个区。我现在在这个区。我知道为了在之前的区时保持最高效，我需要全神贯注。就像，我需要从精神上脱离工作。而且这对我没有帮助
switching between one and the other. I think we also need to learn how to say when a task is finished or finished enough for now. Like this is another thing I find with people who are very motivated, very ambitious. I'm sure you're one of these people. Like there's always more that can go on the to-do list. There's always more that can go on the to-do list. Like there's always going to be something else that hasn't been done. That's why all of these, I think, tasks and all of these tips kind of combine to create a productive day where, you know, you are doing enough. That three to one list, you know by the end of the day that you have completed what is required. I'm sure you've heard of this idea of hedonic adaptation where people get more and more used to pleasure until they
在两者之间切换。我认为我们还必须学会如何说一项任务已经完成，或者对目前来说已经足够完成。就像这是我在非常有动力、非常雄心勃勃的人身上发现的另一件事。我确信你就是这样的人。就像待办事项清单上总能加上更多东西。待办事项清单上总能加上更多东西。就像总会有其他事情没有做完。这就是为什么所有这些，我认为，任务和所有这些提示结合起来，创造了一个富有成效的一天，你知道，你已经做得足够了。那个三对一的清单，你知道到了一天结束时，你已经完成了要求的内容。我确信你听说过享乐适应的概念，人们对快乐越来越习惯，直到他们
need more and more of it. So like it's the same with greed. Like, you know, $100 is a lot until you have $1,000 and then $100 isn't that much. And then you get a million dollars and $1,000 isn't that much anymore either. Like that happens for greed, that happens for enjoyment. It also happens for productivity. I think this is something you need to be very aware of. The more productive you become, the more productive you expect yourself to be. And so dedicating yourself to your rest and being like, all right, I'm going to switch off. Stop you from feeling like, oh my God, this whole day was a waste because it wasn't as good as the day before or the day before that. There are times to be there are times to be off. Even nature understands that. Even the cells that make up your most
需要更多的快乐。所以这和贪婪是一样的。就像，你知道，100美元很多，直到你有了1000美元，然后100美元就没那么多了。然后你得到了100万美元，1000美元也没那么多了。这发生在贪婪身上，这发生在享受身上。这也发生在生产力身上。我认为这是你需要非常清楚的一点。你变得越有生产力，你就越期望自己有生产力。因此，全身心投入休息，告诉自己“好的，我要关闭工作”，可以防止你觉得“天哪，这一天全废了，因为它没有前一天或前几天那么好”。有些时候该工作，有些时候该休息。大自然也明白这一点。甚至组成你最
basic state of being understand the flow of, I guess, creation and reproduction and then also slowness and renewal. You need to be following that as well. It's really just like a wave chart or like a wave structure of like if you want to hit the peaks of your productivity, you have to hit the lows of your rest. So that is all I have. That is my final soapbox moment for this episode. Treat your rest as important as your work. I hope that the combination of these tips was useful. I hope that you found the research helpful to summarize the seven tips so you can just go away with the basics. Implement the three to one method. So three chores, two small tasks, one big task. Eat the frog, so do the hardest task first or when you are most productive.
基本存在状态的细胞也理解创造、繁殖以及缓慢和更新的流动。你也需要效仿这一点。这真的就像波浪图或波浪结构，如果你想触及生产力的巅峰，你必须触及休息的低谷。这就是我全部要说的。这是我本集最后的独白时刻。把你的休息看得和工作一样重要。我希望这些提示的组合是有用的。我希望你觉得这些研究有助于总结这七个技巧，这样你就可以直接掌握基础知识。实施三对一方法。所以三个杂务，两个小任务，一个大任务。吃掉青蛙，所以先把最难的任务做完，或者在你最高效的时候做完。
Speaking of when you are most productive, learn your chronotype when you are going to be the most on. Habit stack, reject all or nothing thinking, carve out some time to be productive in an enjoyable, spontaneous way, i.e. with a shoot your shot Wednesday, and take your rest seriously. That is all. If you have any further tips, so you can always leave them in the comments down below. If you are listening on Spotify, a big thank you to our researcher, Libby Cobbert for her help with today's episode. Reminder, we're on Netflix, we're on Substack, we're on Instagram. We'd love to see you over there.
说到你什么时候最高效，了解你的昼夜节律类型，了解你什么时候状态最好。习惯叠加，拒绝非此即彼的思维，留出一些时间以愉快、自发的方式提高生产力，也就是通过“出击周三”，并认真对待你的休息。就是这样。如果你有任何进一步的建议，你总是可以把它们留在下方的评论中。如果你在 Spotify 上收听，非常感谢我们的研究员莉比·科伯特（Libby Cobbert）对今天节目的帮助。提醒一下，我们在 Netflix 上，在 Substack 上，在 Instagram 上。我们很乐意在那里见到你。
And whatever it is you're working towards, whether it is your dissertation, I don't know, a big work project. Oh my God, I can only ever think in like work and school. There's like a thousand things in the middle. Maybe it's an art fair. Maybe it's a marathon. I don't know, whatever it is that you are dedicating yourself to right now. I'm just rooting for you. And I hope that this more sustainable approach to productivity and devotion and success is something that will help you get to where you want to go.
无论你正在为什么努力，无论是你的毕业论文，我不知道，一个大的工作项目。天哪，我总是只能用工作和学校来思考。中间有一千件事情。也许是一个艺术展。也许是一场马拉松。我不知道，无论你现在全身心投入的是什么。我都在为你加油。我希望这种更具可持续性的生产力、奉献精神和成功的方法能够帮助你到达你想去的地方。
So good luck. Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, Portlandia fans. Carrie Brownstein and Fred Armisen here. The dream of the 90s is a lot of. live in podcast form. We're launching Podlandia, AEO rewatch,
所以祝你好运。直到下次，注意安全，保持善良，对自己温柔一些。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，Portlandia的粉丝们。我是Carrie Brownstein和Fred Armisen。90年代的梦想正在以播客的形式...
our brand new podcast where we revisit every episode of Portlandia together, breaking down sketches, going deep on our iconic characters, and pulling back the curtain on how it all got made. And we'll also be joined by the people who helped bring it all to life. Guest stars, collaborators, and friends, including director Jonathan Chrysall,
我们全新播客，我们将一起重温《Portlandia》的每一集，拆解小品，深入探讨我们的标志性角色，并揭开这一切是如何制作的幕后花絮。我们还将邀请那些帮助将其变为现实的人们加入...
the mayor himself, Kyle McLaughlin, legendary musician Amy Mann, and many more. Kyle is going for it here. You fully improvised, not just words, but a song. Well, I thought you were all going to write a song. I remember you thinking that. Listen to Podlandia.
市长本人Kyle McLaughlin，传奇音乐人Amy Mann等等。Kyle在这里全力以赴。你完全即兴创作了，不仅仅是台词，还有一首歌。嗯，我以为你们都要写一首歌。我记得你是这么想的。收听Podlandia。
A.O. Rewatch on the IHeartRadio Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. What's up, fam, it's sports journalist Ari Chambers. Hey, what's up, y'all? It's your girl, Sam J. And we're the hosts of everyone watches women's sports, a new podcast from together. We're breaking down the biggest headlines,
A.O. 重温节目，就在IHeartRadio Podcasts，或者你获取播客的任何地方。大家好，我是体育记者Ari Chambers。嘿，大家好！我是你们的女孩Sam J。我们是《每个人都在看女子体育》的主持人...
the viral moments, and the stories everyone's talking about across women's sports. From game-changing performances to culture-shifting conversations, We'll give you our takes, our debates, and a few lasts along the way. Because everyone watches women's sports. Listen to everyone watches women's sports.
病毒式传播的时刻，以及每个人在女子体育界都在谈论的故事。从改变比赛的表现到改变文化的对话，我们将沿途给出我们的看法、辩论和一些笑声。因为每个人都在看女子体育。收听《每个人都在看女子体育》。
On the IHeart Radio app. Apple Podcasts or wherever you get your podcast. This is Chelsea Handler from Dear Chelsea. Every week, the news gets worse. The world gets crazier. And Yamanika is here to tell whoever's responsible, you're the problem. Do you know I just found out who Sidney Sweeney was? If he got a bunch of women, then I should have a bunch of men.
在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方。我是来自《亲爱的切尔西》的切尔西·汉德勒。每周，新闻都在变糟。世界变得越来越疯狂。而Yamanika在这里告诉任何负责任的人，你才是问题所在。你知道我刚刚发现西德尼·斯威尼是谁吗？如果他有一群女人，那么我也应该有一群男人。
Do better or do less so I don't have to do so much. I'm Yamanika and I'm out. Listen to you're the problem with Yamanika on the I Heart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. I'm Jake Brennan, and on the Disgraceland podcast, I explore the wild lives of rock stars and unbelievable true crime stories from music history. These are the stories you haven't heard, the kind you'll end up telling someone else. Like the time Paul McCartney spent in a notorious prison or the bizarre crime Lady Gaga is accused of where that time blondeies Debbie Harry escaped Ted Bunny.
做得更好，或者做得少一点，这样我就不用做那么多了。我是Yamanika，我先走了。在I Heart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听Yamanika的《你就是问题所在》。我是杰克·布伦南，在《Disgraceland》播客中，我探索摇滚明星的狂野生活和音乐史上难以置信的真实犯罪故事。这些是你没听过的事情，那种你会忍不住告诉别人的故事。比如保罗·麦卡特尼在臭名昭著的监狱里度过的时光，或者Lady Gaga被指控的离奇犯罪，或者当年金发女郎黛比·哈里逃脱泰德·邦迪的故事。
Listen to disgrace land on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. My first guest is Paris Hilton, Shakira, Luke and Yerrin. Have surprises? Many surprises. Welcome to the Sweet 305 podcast where the group chat comes to life. What on?
在Iheart Radio App、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听disgrace land。我的第一位嘉宾是帕丽斯·希尔顿、夏奇拉、卢克和Yerrin。有惊喜吗？有很多惊喜。欢迎来到《Sweet 305》播客，群聊在这里变为现实。在...
You're the only person I know that loves a yellow starburst. It's lemonade. This is Sweet 305. Here, oversharing is encouraged. Listen to Sweet 305 with Lele Pons on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你是我认识的唯一一个喜欢黄色星爆糖的人。那是柠檬味的。这是《Sweet 305》。在这里，过度分享受到鼓励。在IHeart Radio App、Apple Podcast或你获取播客的任何地方收听Lele Pons主持的《Sweet 305》。这是一个IHeart播客。保证由真人制作。本集暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。